basking in a hue of purple
landmarks across the country salute the
fall
candles illuminated in windows mark a
national moment of mourning
as the country remembers the millions
murdered in the holocaust
for simply existing
lily ebert's family are among them
tonight she lit a candle in their memory
what a terrible
the worst crime what it could have
happened
happened in the 20th century
and i family was a part of it
my mother applied to the british embassy
for a british passport for me
looking back that action saved my
life it is described as one of the worst
stains on human history
this year holocaust memorial day's
virtual ceremony
remembered all victims of genocide i was
so
happy you know i didn't need
your husband the sharing of survivors
stories is a powerful reminder of
humanity's
ultimate capacity for evil the duchess
of cambridge
and the prime minister both heard from
those who feel bound to tell
and retell while they still can he
disappeared like into thin air i never
saw him again
at the event ceremony the prince of
wales called out those not willing to
listen
we've also seen reckless assaults
on the truth and the deeply worrying
growth of fake news
and of irrational theories not grounded
in reality
but rooted in dark places of hatred and
fear
survivors say it's the responsibility of
younger generations to share their
plight
like the students of hampton school
we've had lots of holocaust survivors
coming to the school um when the boys
say and they ask this question every
time they say why do you do this
why'd you come in uh and tell us about
really traumatic
horrific experiences and they say to the
boys
um you are now the witness to my
testimony
and because you're now the witness what
you need to do
is you need to go out into the world you
need to educate other people
exactly 76 years since one of the
darkest chapters in the history of
humankind came to an end
today light symbolizes unity and a vow
to many
to never forget ashley harinag skyny